the left does want to take away your
right to self-defense because they don't
believe that you should defend yourself
against people that have already been
victimized by Society I've said this
before the left believes that the people
that like Jordan himself was a victim he
had been victimized all his life he was
a victim of circumstance victim of a
system etc etc so when you have someone
that's victimized like that and he's
just acting out in this terrible world
that he's been oppressed in and then the
white man comes and kills him and that's
the way that's the entirety of the
left's you know outlook on it and so the
the white guy has come and victimized
the black guy at the end of the day and
they can't abide by the idea that he was
victimized again by historically
powerful people Etc